では よろしくお願いします
今日はダンマパダの六十八番目の偈でございます
タムチャカンマンカタンサードゥヤンカトワナアヌタッパティ
ヤッサパティートースマノヴィパーカンパティセーバティ
ということで これもすごくこの簡単な偈だとは思います
タムチャカンマン カンマンというのは行為ですね
タムチャカンマンというのは
まあこのような行為ということで
まあカタンサードゥ カタン
行った方がサードゥ良いことであると
よろしいと このような行為をした方がよろしいということで
どのようなということは次に来るんですね
ヤンカトワ まあそれをしたところでナアヌタッパティ
悩むことにはなりません
アヌタッパティっていうのは何か考えて心の中で悩むことなんですね
何かについて悩むこと
いわゆる後悔することですね
後悔することにならない行為はした方がよろしいという意味なんです
ヤッサパティートースマノヴィパーカンパティセーバティ
さらにその行為に対して説明しますね
パティートースマノ 大変
パティータというのは喜びを感じるということで
スマノっていうのはまた清らかなもう喜びの心なんですね
パティータというのは
その場合はこの すごく充実して充実感があって
喜びの心が生まれて ヴィパーカンパティセーバティ
その果報を受けると だからまあ訳はいつでももうもう後ろから元に行かないと日本語的にはなりませんからね
ヴィパーカンパティセーバティ
果報を受ける場合はパティートースマノ
充実感に溢れた喜ぶ喜ぶ心があるならばっていうことです
そのような行為をした方がよろしいと
で まあものすごい当たり前のことなんですね
いろんなことを人々はする
この自分がやったこと
したことによって すごい充実感が出てきて
大変素晴らしい結果が出てくる
楽しみになる そのような行為をまあした方がよろしいと
問題は 結果が後から出てくるんだからね
だから当たり前のことなんですけど
ちょこっと難しいところはあります
結果がよろしいんだったら
そのことはした方がいいというのはわかりますけど
まあやっていることで結果が良く
いい結果が出るか 悪い結果が出るかっていうことはちょっとわからないんですね
だからそこら辺はやっぱり難しいところなんですよ
なぜならば この仏教は知らない世界ではみんなとにかく何か何かやってるんですよ
やってから結局どんな結果になるかわからないんですね
それで結果になったところで
まずい結果になったら
ずっとそれで落ち込んだり悩んだりする
良い結果になったらエラく舞い上がったりして
傲慢になって もうかなり恐ろしいことをまたやったりもするし
だから普通の世界では
我々はこうやることっていうのは
なんかくじを引くような感じなんですね
くじを引く場合は凶を引くか吉引くかわからないでしょうに
くじを引いた 大凶だとかね
あ これはもう小吉やとかね
そういう風に後でもそれによって悩んだり困ったりする
だから世の中の人間の人生っていうのはくじ引きの人生なんですね
だから行為は三種類ですよ
それも世間はあべこべで考えてますね
我々行為と言った途端
もう体でやっていることだと思っちゃいますね
いろんな体で 今日も大阪から東京までいらっしゃっているし
これ体でやっている行為なんですね
いろいろ新幹線に乗ったり
いろいろ朝早く起きたり
昨日からもきよかさんがいらっしゃってるし
まあそういう そうすると体力
体使ってるんですね 大体世の中では体でやる行為はもう大胆に考えちゃうんです
次のこと 行為っていうのは言葉ない
喋ることなんですね 喋ることっていうのはそんなに価値入れてないんですね
次の行為は考えることなんですね
それには全然価値を入れてないんです
どうったことないんだと
もう考えただけだと しかし
仏教はそれは逆にしているんです
一番最大の行為は考えることで
それより小さい行為は喋ることで
それよりも小さい行為は体でやることなんです
そういうことですから
行為は三種類あります
一番力の強い行為は心でやっている行為なんですね
心でやっている行為といったっても
心で何かできるんでしょうかね
心できるのはもう考えることなんですね
思考することなんですね
しかし 思考っていうのはあまりしないでしょうし
あんまりもう見つからないんですよ
思考する人っていうのは
ただごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ何か考えてるだけで
いわゆる妄想なんですね
あまりテーマ決めてないし
どこまで考えるのかとも決めてないし
何のために考えるかも決めてないし
だからテーマを決めて目的があって
その目的に達するところまで考えることは思考なんですね
ですから 思考っていうのはいつでもあるガイドラインがあって
いわゆる照準感があって
照準しながら管理しながら考えるんですよ
しかし 人間にはその照準感はないんです
コントロールルームはないんです
ただ考えている それは仏教ではもうもう
管理できない思考だからね
暴走するんですね 止めようとしたって止める方法もなくなっちゃうんですね
で そこは一番最大の罪になりますし
良いことになっても最大の良いことにもなります
それで 本来すべての生命は無知でしょうし
無知っていうのは真理をありのままに見ることはしないということで
ありのままに見ることはしないということも
どういうことかというと
心というのは認識するためには時間
取っちゃうんですね だから心はもともと弱くて
この あ これは何やとわかるためには時間取るんですよ
だから時間取ってから認識すると
もうそのそのものははっきりわからなくなっちゃうんです
なぜならば 物事っていうのはものすごいスピードで変化していくんですね
だから一秒ぐらい時間取ってデータをまとめて認識すると
データをもう一つ塊で取らなくちゃいけないんですね
でも塊のデータはないんです
ずっと流れるものなんですね
だから我々時間取りますから
どうしてもありのままに見ることはできないんです
そういうことで 本来は無知でしょうし
それで自分勝手に認識するでしょうし
それから心の中で怒り
憎しみ 嫉妬 欲などなどいっぱい感情があるし
だから感情があるんだから感情に合わせて合わせて
あの なんていうかね ねつ造するんですね
入るデータを ねつ造して自分で認識するんですね
だからある環境でいて一人が楽しくなってるし
一人が嫌な気分でいるし
一人がイライラしているし
一人が面白くないといて寝込んだりするし
同じ環境なんですけど
で 人はバラバラなんですね
なんでそうなるんですかと
例えば同じ部屋で３人がいると環境は同じ
テレビがつけているならば
テレビから流れるデータも同じなんですね
なのに３人は同じ認識はしないんです
それぞれ自分勝手に耳に目に入るデータをねつ造するんですよ
だからねつ造するということは明らかな事実で ３
人いれば考え方は３つになりますからね
同じ考え方にはなりません
それでデータをねつ造する場合は
どうしても貪瞋痴で 欲怒り無知でねつ造するんです
自分の感情で で 感情っていうのはまた人をみんな同じっていうことでもないんですね
で それで思考が回転しているんだから
そこはものすごい最大な悪行為になります
なんで考えることは最大の悪行為になるのかというと
やっぱり生きてるっていうことは心が回転していることなんですよ
生きてるんだから喋ってるんです
生きてるんだからご飯食べてるんで
生きてるんだからいろんなことやってますよ
生きてなきゃ何もやりませんね
だから全ての行為の大本は生きてるっていうことなんですよ
生きてるっていうことは
心が回転しているということなんです
だから回転している心が指導して権を取って
親分の役割を果たして
で 命令してやらせてるんですね
だから最高司令官は自分の思考なんですね
ということで もう一番重い行為は考えることで
次に重い行為は 次 まあ重さは低いんですけど
喋ることなんですね で
喋ることで もうかなり良いことをすることも
かなり悪いことをすることもできますよ
ただ喋るだけで ただ喋るだけでどれほどのことをできるのかと
並のことじゃないんですね
世の中で我々本を読んだり
新聞 雑誌読んだりする場合も
喋る行為なんですよ ただ喋るものはもう文字になってるだけのことで
だから我々はそうやって喋る情報をたくさん入れて
いろんなことをやっています
戦争したければ それもまず喋って喋って始めなくちゃいけないんですよ
喋らなくては成り立ちません
で それで仏教では まあ手足で情報を伝えることも喋ることにしているんです
手で人を呼ぶ場合でも
それも喋ることなんです
それから重さ 小さいのは体でやることなんです
世の中 そこはすごい大きく考えているんです
例えば人に喋ることによって 100
人でも殺すことはできますよ
言葉で いろんなことを言って
いろんな人をもう興奮させて
もう何て言いますか もう感情がこみ上げるようにしてあげて
もうお互い殺し合いするようにすることは簡単にできます
ただ喋るだけで しかし
その人に自分の体で100人殺せるかというと
それはできないんですよ
一番恐ろしい罪っていうのは心で考えることなんです
だから妄想っていうのはものすごい危険視しないと
妄想だけでいとも簡単に地獄に落ちますよ
何にも悪いことしていないんだと世間言うかもしれませんよ
人に怒鳴ったことはないんだと
何も悪いことをしたことはないない人やと言っても
頭の中で妄想しているならば
もう知ったものじゃないんですよ
だから 自分の幸福を目指す人々っていうのは
確実に やっぱり自分自身の思考は何なと何なのかと
それを気をつけないと
思考が全て破壊するんですよ
本人に能力ある人間であっても
もうくだらん妄想 もう脱線して妄想を始めて
もう能力ひとかけらもなくなくなっちゃいます
で やがて地獄に落ちる羽目にもなります
ですから この 仏教ではそういうふうに一番ものすごく正しく
事実ありのままに語っているんです
そちらにはもう微妙にも微塵にも間違いはないんです
ブッダの言葉には ちょっと見てみればその通りということになるんです
それで このお釈迦様の時代で
ジャイナ教という宗教がありまして
その宗教はやっぱり体の行為は一番重いんだと
言葉の行為はそんな重いことはないんだと
心の声はもっとちっぽけなものでも気にすることでもないんだよと言っているんです
そちらはものすごいしっかりしたことを喋っているんだと
例えば人を殺すことを考えることって
殺したいと考えることってどうったことないでしょうにと
それよりは殺しますよあなたをと言って脅すことはもっと罪ではないかと
それよりその人を殺すこと
もっとひどいでしょうと
明らかではないかと 殺したいと思って黙っている人は全然罪をわかっていないと
殺すと脅した人はもう黙っている人より罪をわかっているんだと
それより殺した人は一番犯人で悪いんじゃないかと
だから体の行為が一番悪いと決めているんですね
それは皆様にも納得いけると思いますけどね
ブッダの話は納得いきませんだからね
で その人々 人と仏教のお坊さんたちを集めたところで
仏教のお坊さんたちをもうからかわれたんですね
あなた方おかしいんだと
考えるぐらいっていうのは何のこともないでしょうと
それより体にやってる
ことは一番重い罪だよと
それぐらいのことわからないのかと
で その話はお釈迦様に言って
お釈迦様が対話したんですよ
で 全部今思い出せませんだけど
一つは一つだけポイントがありまして
最後のもう決まりのポイントだって
お釈迦様はこのジャイナ教の修行から質問するんですね
一つはジャイナ教の苦行をしますから
あのジャイナの教の人々はね
で 相手に聞いたんで あなた方の場合はね
修行する修行者いるでしょうと
その中で で 完全にね 水を飲まないように苦行するとか
ご飯食べないように苦行するとかね
断食で苦行する いろいろ苦行あります
それでこの苦行は一応年間やらなくちゃいけないんですけど
そこでもしある修行者がいるとしましょうと
その人は真剣真面目に苦行するとしますと
しかし 苦行はあまりにも厳しいんだから
あの年とか年間とかね
それはもう苦行はできなくて
途中で死にますよと いわゆる心汚れたままで
煩悩があるままで まあ苦行しようとしたところで
体って弱い時もありますから
もうみんなにそんな体力あるわけじゃないし
体弱い人は苦行に励んじゃうと日二日で死ぬ可能性もあるし
ですから まあ修行始めたばかりで死んだとしますよと
そうするとその人はどこに生まれますか？と
あなた方の教えではと言ったら
その人はもう天国なんか展開で天国に生まれますよと
なんで天国に生まれますか？って言ったら
使ってる単語はマノーサッタというね
これはジャイナ教の単語はパーリ語にしていますね
自分の企業に対してマノーサッタということがあったんだからと
マノーサッタというのはあの
なんでしょうかね 本人の気持ちというかね
苦行 真面目に苦行して解脱したいというかね
ジャイナ教では解脱は
何といいますかね 別の名前なんですけど
ケーベリーってね 単語使ってますけどね
涅槃という単語を使いません
涅槃という単語は仏教だけの単語でね
解脱とはヴィムッティとかはどんな宗教でも使ってます
ケーベリーという言葉を使っても
ケーベリーっていうのはもうパーフェクトっていう意味なんですね
完成になりましたと 魂が
そこでこの業者行者がそちらに心が透けておいたんだから
解脱することに いわゆるもう
に心つけておいたんだから
天界に生まれます と言ったら
お釈迦様ね あのね ちょっと気をつけて喋ってくださいと
あんた何言ったんだ今はと
マノーサッタったでしょうにと
だから心がそういうことにつけてあったんだから
天国に生まれるという
あんた言ってること違うんじゃないか
矛盾じゃないかなと で
それでもうその人々が負けてしまったんです
で 結局は心なしに何も成り立たないというブッダの立場なんですね
だから人々はヘリックスで
ジャイナ教では心という考え方はないんですけど
魂ということ 魂が物事を知っていますよと
だから知るということは魂の機能なんですね
魂はいつでも全知全能であると
誰の魂でも全知全能であると
だったらなんで何も知らないんでしょうかというと
もう汚れているんだから
何に汚れてるか 体で汚れているんだと
だから体をもう苦行でいじめなくちゃいけないんですね
いじめていくと 体 魂が体から抜けます
抜けたところで全知全能である
ブッダは魂という言葉を使わないんですからね
心ということだからね
だから結局は知るのは魂であって
魂のために苦行やっているんであって
結局は心ということになるんです
だから行為の中で一番強いというか
まあ命そのものですからね
心は 命そのものですから
それは汚れると全部汚れちゃいますよ
歩いたり喋ったり交尾したりするのは生きているんだからであって
そちらにはそんなに基本的な価値がないので
二次的な価値しかないんです
生きているんだからご飯を食べるんであって
ご飯を食べるために生きているということは成り立たないんです
ご飯を食べるために生きることはできません
まあみんなそう ほとんどそう思ってますけどね
まあ楽しむために ご飯を食べるために
ふざけるために生きているんだとと言いながら
美人でも喜びは感じませんし
笑うことはできませんし
ちょっと冗談でも何か面白い話でも言ったら腹が立つし
矛盾ばっかりなんですけど
だから食べるために生きているんだよということは言っても
実はそれは不可能ですよ
生きてるんだから食べてるんです
楽しむために生きてるんだよと言ったら
いくらでも生きていられるでしょうに
でもできませんでしょうね
生きてるんだから楽しみを探しているだけのことですよ
だから生きてるっていうことは基本的なところで
そこが汚れると もうどうにもならないんですね
そういうことで 思考が一番重い罪ということはよく覚えておかなくちゃいけないんです
そこで問題は じゃあ考える
考えることで良い結果になるか悪い結果になるか
我々はわかりません とにかく考える
考えることで悪い結果になったら
それから悩んだりする
で 結果に当たるんですね
なんで私はこんなことにならなくちゃいけないんでしょうかとかね
結果出た時はもう結果に当たっても意味がないんですよ
もうどうすることもできないんですよ
結果が出る場合は ただ喋る
喋ったところでまずい結果になる
それから結果をごまかそうとかね
逃げようとかね それはもうできませんよ
結果から逃げません 世間はいつでもそういうことをしようとするんで
人を殺したりしますよ
殺してからとにかく逃げることばっかり考えるんですね
いろいろ工夫して いろいろカラクリして
結果から逃げよう逃げようと
その馬鹿どもたちが知らないのは
逃げよう逃げようとすることでも
自分の悪行為の結果得ているっていうことなんですけど
あるいは何かごまかしやったり
いろんなことをやったりして
それからそればれないようにと必死でものすごい真剣に怯えてあらゆる工夫をしているんですね
例えば年間自分がいろいろ税金ごまかしたり
いろんな会社のお金を横領したりごまかしたりしたとしますね
その人 まだバレてないんだから大丈夫だと思ってます
それでバレないようにずっと苦労していますよ
本人がずっと気づいてないんですけど
自分の悪行為の結果 もうとっくに得ているんです
そこでそれがバレて逮捕されると
あ しまったとかね 失敗しまったとかねと思うんであって
そういうことじゃないんです
もうずっと結果得ているんです
えっと面白いエピソードがあります
それは作り話ですよ しかし
結果から逃げられないという作り話のエピソードで
まあ自分の国のエピソードだからね
ちょっと文化的に理解できないところあるかもしれませんけど
まあインド文化っていうのは星占いはまあ頑固と信じています
それでこの人間の運命っていうのは
この九つの星でしたっけね
まあ星座がありまして
その九つの星の間で回転するんですね
まあ名前はこの惑星の名前を付けてますからね
ビーナスとかサターンとかね
サターンというのは土星
ビーナスというのは金星ですね
それからそういうものと
またとにかくこの九つの星ですね
そこでそのその星座に人の運命を管理する日にちも決まってます
で ビーナスは年かな サターンというのは土星は年なんですよ
年間 それで一番悪いと思っているのは
もう不幸と思ってるのは土星なんです
だから土星の運命が参り込んじゃうと
年間も気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
それでこの これは運命だから
まあまあまあみんなもう信じながら冗談を言う
からかうというね それまた面白いんですけど
で いくらなんでも神様には星占い関係ないでしょ
ヒンドゥー教ではね しかし
もう世界を創るのはブラフマ神様で支配してではなくて
維持して管理しているのはヴィシュヌ神様で
破壊するのはシヴァ神様なんですね
三人で だから一番仕事多いのはヴィシュヌ神様なんですよ
ブラフマさんが作って
それでもうはい知らんということで
もう何も知りません しません
それから作ったものは整理整頓して
ずーっともう生命が破壊するまでヴィシュヌ神様が苦労しなくちゃいけないんですね
世界を守るために 何か不幸が出てくると
人類がもうそうそう破滅したら良くないんだからね
そこを何とかして まあ時期によっていろんな不幸な時期が出てくる
その時はもうヴィシュヌ神様がとんと出てきて
人類を守ってくれるんですね
仕事は多いんですけど
それでも時期になったらもうシヴァ神様
私の仕事やとできて 全部一発でもう破壊する
その二人には仕事はそれほどはないんです
これでヴィシュヌ神様にもこの星占いでこの土星の影響を与える時期が来ましたと
それでヴィシュヌ神様は神様だから全部知ってるんです
来年から土星ですね 私にはね
あいつはもうかなり人をいじめるんだと
だからこの星座の神様
神々だからお互い話したりもする
そこでこの意地悪な土星の神様があの前もってあと二年ですね
私の仕事はねとかね じゃあ待っててくださいとかね
それから年間もクッタクタいじめるんだからね
病気になったり 怪我したり
もう大変なことになり
財産なくなったりとかね
年間も じゃあ待っててくださいと
ヴィシュヌ神様が考えて
こいつにもうハメられると
酷なことはないんだと
なんかいい方法ないのかと
思って ちょうどこの土星の運命が帰ってくる瞬間で
ヴィシュヌ神様が隠れたんです
どういうふうに隠れたかというと
変身できますからね 象に変身したんです
象に変身して 森の中にもう天国もいない
もういないで森の中で草食べているんですね
ヴィシュヌ様 神様がほら
お前に私を見つかりっこはないぞと
どうせヴィシュヌ神様の立場が上でしょうしね
そこで象さんでずっと 年間もいるんですよ
そろそろ 年終わったらまた天国に戻って
まあ土星の神様にアンタどうあなたの仕事はやったんでしょうかねとか
年間私をいじめる計画でしたでしょうと
そしたら土星の神様 あんた 年間草食べてたんじゃないの？神様のくせに
あんた神様のくせに年間草食べてたでしょ
あれ美味しかった 結局やられてるということで
まあそれはまあもう占い信じてる人はね
まあ占いは確実に効きますよ
たとえ神様であっても
ということを言うために言うエピソードですけど
私はそれは他の仏教のことを言うために借りただけで
面白いエピソードですよ
神様でも逃げられません
運命からは だから悪いことをする人は自分たちが逃げたつもりですけど
結局は結果は受けているんです
人殺して年間 日本では年間だからね
で隠れていたんだと年間怯えることはどういうことですかね
怯えてもう 1箇所でいたらバレちゃうでしょうね
名前変えて変えていたっても
どうしてもどこかであパートを借りて仕事をしているとね
もうこれはバレますよ
また別なところに行って
またもう仕事を見つからないしね
知らない人だから疑われるし
怪しいと思われるし 楽じゃないんですよ
そうでなくても ものすごくずっとあれ忘れることはできないんですよ
それより逮捕されちゃう
もしかするとね もう犯罪
罪は必ずしも死刑ということでもないんだからね
いろいろ条件によって調べて
それなりの判決でしょうに
もしかすると年とかになる可能性もあるし
時々年で終わる可能性もあるし
年で終わる可能性もあるし
恐ろしい犯罪者だったらまあ処刑になりますけど
その場合 そういう人々は逃げようとしませんしね
例えばその人は捕まったならば
自分で自首したならば年で終わる可能性もあったしね
年終わったらもう 俗世間的にはもうもう何も罪を犯した人間として扱ってはいけないんだからね
罪は償ったんだから だから逃げたでしょうかと
逃げられません それから逃げよう逃げようする行為自体も罪ですから
その人は人を殺したということで
悪いことをしちゃったということで
ずーっといて刑務所に十年ぐらいいると償っているんだと
それでまああんたもう終わりですから
帰ってください よし わかります
これから立派な真面目な人間でいるぞということでもう思考が明るく暗くならないんですよ
それからまともな人間になれることってのはいくらでもできますからね
あなたに仕事をあげます
あなた人を殺したことある
そういう意味言いませんよ
普通は 誰でも その場合はやっぱりいい人間になってほしい
人間になってほしいって気持ちにもなるし
だからかえって逃げることによって
自分の罪をさらにさらにさらに
大きくするだけ だから逃げられません
それでこの無知な人間は何か行為をする前に
これは良い結果になるのか
悪い結果になるのかということは知らないんですよ
だから行為行為自体が良いか悪いかっていう明確な判断は
判断ありますよ 他の宗教でも
しかし 明確に  数学の何て言うんですか
フォーミュラは公式みたいな感じでしっかりしていないんですよ
例えば聖書の中でもね
欲張ってはいけませんとか
なんだかんだありますけど
はっきりした公式は書いてないんですね
明確に 基本的には神を裏切ったことが行為の悪の元であるというね
それは論理は成り立たないんですね
自分が作った作品が自分を裏切ったならば
この作者の問題であって
作った人間が罪を犯すか良いこと神を信仰するかということは
その人に自由を与えたならば
その人は自分の自由をどう使ってもいいでしょうに
それも言うんですね 神様は人間
イスラム教でも神様は人間創って人間に自由を与えたんだと
だからあんた方は罪を犯している
地獄落ちますよと 落ちませんよ
地獄に 自由を与えたならば
神様が自由を与えたならば
こちら自由を使っているだけでしょうに
だから神を信じるか否定するかという自由があるんだから
それも結局神様のせいでしょうに
だから地獄に落ちるべきなのは神様なんです
だからまあ論理成り立ってないんですよ
だから喋るは喋るはもう膨大に書くは書くは哲学作るは
いくら作っても もう意味がないんですよ
だって妄想っていうのはいくらでも喋れますからね
結論が出たらそれで話終わりますからね
結論のない話ですからね
そういうわけで この悪いことはもう当然キリスト教でもいろいろこれは悪い
あれ悪いとありますよ
イスラム教でもこれはやってはいけない
これやっていけないとか
盗んではいけないとかね
ちゃんとありますよ 殺してはならないとかね
あるんだけど しっかりした善悪判断はないんですね
いつでも矛盾で ちょっとでも考えたらとんでもないことになるので
だから考えることは禁止するんですよ
イスラム教でもキリスト教でも
あの最初に食べた何でしたっけ
あの禁断の実っていうね
あれは知恵の実と言うでしょ
あの木はTREEOF WISDOMなんですね
それで目が覚めたんだと
これが随分大変なことで
仏教では目が覚めること自体が人間にとって幸福ではないかというところで
だからこの正反対ですね
宗教としては 似てないんです
どんな宗教もいいことを教えてるんだということじゃないんですよ
やっぱり宗教学的には全くも立場が違います
あのゴーン・ブリッジ教授だけですね
正直に物事をしゃべるのは
あれがなんかキリスト教のあの国際信奉誌に向かって宗教のね
だからいろんな宗教の人々あって
まあ教授たちだけね 一流の
で 彼が仏教のセクションでもう喋るために来ていて
すっごい頭のいい ものすごい先生ですよ
で 彼のレポート読んでみたら
もう彼がね こういうInterreligious Conferenceなんかには仏教を呼ばないでくださいと
仏教は明らかに世界宗教の一つですけど
しかし仏教は呼ばないでくださいと
仏教とあなた方の思考とまるっきり一致しないんだよと
堂々と言うんです まるっきり一致しませんよと
何の共通点もありませんと
全く正反対だと だからこれは無意味だよと
世界のために 人類のために
あらゆるみんなの宗教が集めて何とかしようかなといったら
もう勝手にしろよと あなた方は
ということで すごい学問的にもうデータ出して
もう彼の だから彼は一番諸宗派だから
もう参加する人々はみんな神様を信じてる
いろんな研究者たちでしょうね
でも あの人は一人で行って
仏教のことを喋って帰ってしまってるんですけど
彼がお坊さん的にはかなり悪口言いますよ
このゴムペジさんは でも全部もうしっかりと言ってるんです
言われたっても全然嫌な気分になりません
言ってること本当だからしょうがないと
いう気分になるんです
ですから この 学者の間では
もうその現代生きてる人の中で
その方でね 前は一人二人ぐらいいたんですけどね
やっぱりみんな仏教学者であろうともね
あんまりこの知り尽くしてないんですね
ブッダの教えは 一部一部学ぶだけでね
一部の研究家になるだけで
まあ幅広いんだからどうしようもないしね
だから仏教っていうのは基本的にウィズダム
智慧ということで だからお釈迦様が悟ったところで目が現れたと
チャックン ウデパーディ
初転法輪経で まずその言葉で始まる
それで幸福になりましたと
アローク ウデパーディ
光が現れたと 光というのは智慧ってことなんです
パンニャー ウデパーディ
智慧も現れ 智慧現れたと
ヴィッジャー ウデパーディ
ノレッジというサイエンスということ意味なんですよ
本当の知恵 本当の知ということ
知識現れましたと だからそこが悪の種として一神教では言ってるんですね
人間が物事を判断することはね
だからこの善悪は何なのかというしっかりした公式がないんです
それがお釈迦様はもう智慧の世界だから
ヴィッジャーの いわゆるサイエンスの世界だから
このヴィッジャー ヴィッダーということは
我々はこのサイエンスということ
サイエンスとはヴィッジャーというんですよ
いわゆる ラテン語でロジとLOGYつけるものっていうのはサンスクリット語
パーリ語 シンハラ語になってくるとヴィッジャーなんですね
ズーロジとかね サイコロジとかね
エピステモロジとかね
そういう学問が全部ロジで終わっちゃうんですよ
サイロジと 全部ロジです
いわゆる論理的にデータをしっかりと調べて研究して組み立てられている知識世界ですね
その単語でロジだけ仏教使ってるんです
ヴィッジャー・オブ・パーリ
私は仏教はほとんど心理学だよと言ったっても
それはブッダに対して正しい表現ではありません
心理学って言ったらロジの一部だけでしょうに
一部じゃないんです 全体的に全部語ってますからね
生命の 生命に対して 生命が完全に幸福になる
完全たる解脱の境地まで語ってるんだから
これはもう完全 お釈迦様はいつでも完全
完全という言葉を使うんですね
はい そういうわけで 善悪の判断の場合のこの公式が仏教にはしっかりありますね
だから二つですね 公式は二つ類にしているんです
で わかりやすい公式が微妙に実行しにくいところもあります
わかりやすい公式が自分の幸福になるのか
他の人々の幸福になるのか
全ての一般的に普遍的に誰の幸福になるのかっていうことなんですね
いわゆる結果で調べなさいと
だから結果どうなるのかとやる前にチェックしなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 考える前に 喋る前に
行為をする前に この行為は幸福になる行為でしょうかと
チェックしなくちゃいけない
だからチェックの順番が
第一 自分の幸福になるのかっていうこと
で なぜならばそれはもう理解しやすいんですね
自分のことだから 次に自分
自分の幸福になるんだからといって善にはなりません
まさか周りの迷惑になる可能性はあります
自分の幸福になるんだけど
わかりました はい その一段落は OK やと
次に周りのことを考えなくちゃいけないんですね
周りに結果どうでしょうかと
周りに迷惑だったらそこでアウト
もう悪なんですね わかりやすい
もう長持ちしませんね
自分だけ良ければ良くて
周りにすごい迷惑だというと長持ちしません
一回 二回だけですよ 周りは反対するんだから
それで不幸になってしまいます
自分が楽しいと思って
自分だけ楽しいと何かやっちゃうと
周りに迷惑だったら周りはそれに攻撃するんだから
訴えますから それから不幸になるでしょ
ですから 自分だけ楽しむ行為は悪行為なんですね
その時点で ですから 周りにどうでしょうかと二番目のステージで考えなくちゃいけないんですね
それで あ 周りにもいい結果になりますよと
周りにいい結果になるならば
このセカンドステージクリアなんですよ
そうすると 自分の楽しみをやると周りにも楽しみになりますから
それなりには応援してくれます
だから あれより一番目よりは長持ちはする
長持ちはします しかし
それではうまくいかないんです
一般的にみんなにどうでしょうかと
社会にどうでしょうかと
あるグループにはいいんだけど
社会に迷惑だったら すると社会が攻撃するんですね
社会がそのグループを潰しちゃうんですよ
社会の攻撃は一番恐ろしいというか
もう反撃はできないんです
社会に対して 社会が反対したら
どんな組織も潰れます
逮捕されます ですから
三番目のステージで社会に対して迷惑か
ためになるのかっていうことを考えなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで 社会にも役に立つんだと
社会のためになるんだと判断すれば
それで堂々とその行為をやるだけ
その場合はもういくらでも長持ちします
自分がその行為をやればやるほど
自分は楽しいし 周りは楽しいし
どんどんその良い影響が社会にまで広げていくんですね
だからみんな応援するんであって
助けてくれるんであって
反対して潰すということはないんですね
だからそれが善行為を善か悪かという判断する基準でというか公式で
で しっかりしているとは思いますよ
もう曖昧はなし 厳密に理論的にそうやって設定する
しかし それでも 分かりやすいんだけど
判断はまた信頼できないんですよ
判断というものは だから
やる前に公式に当ててみて
正しいと結果が出たらやるんだけど
やってる間でもチェックしなきゃいけないんですよ
なぜならば ちょこっとやったらその分結果がありますから
これでそのサンプルでまた再びチェックすることができますよ
1週間やってみたんだ
どういう結果はと それでも3段階で OK出たらまたやってみるんですよ
だからやってる途中でいつでも調べてみる
調べてみるという だから知恵っていうのは観察能力
いつでも考えて行動する
責任を持って行動するということは
仏教にはどうしても必要なんですね
だから他の宗教とは明確に実質的には反対という全く反対側に立ってます
で そういうことで 自分に判断ミスあったとしても
悪い結果はいつでも最小限ではあるんです
行為をしている間でもチェックしてますから
こういうちょこっと行為したところで結果どうでしょうか
良いでしょうかとね やっぱりちょっとまずいなと分かったら
これ悪行為だ やめます
そこでやめますからね
だから悪結果というのはいつでも最小限になるようなセッティングさんですよ
それで じゃあその子やって終わったとする
やって終わったら結果もはっきりしているんです
もう結果は変わることできません
それで明確な判断できるんですね
自分が行った行為は善行為でしょうか
悪行為でしょうかと 結果が悪ければ悪行為で
結果が幸福だったら善行為ですから
で 終わってから判断する
終わってから判断は何の役に立ちますかね
それは次の判断の役に立ちます
だから次に判断するよりは
前の判断よりマチな判断できるようになります
そういうことで この一番簡単にわかりやすい公式っていうのは
まあ実行になってくると結構ややこしく難しいんですけど
次の公式は ものすごいしっかりしています
悪の原因は貪瞋痴であると
心の感情ですからね 貪瞋痴がない状況は善だと
それで悪は小さいんです
リミットあるんですね
貪瞋痴ですからね 心に悪があると心はどうしても小さくなりますよ
心に欲が出てくると狭くなるんですよ
みんな欲があるとすごい広げるともそうじゃなくて
心ずっと狭くなるんです
心の範囲はね 縄張りが
自分が欲張ってる対象の中で閉じ込められます
怒りが出てくると 何か対象に対して怒ってるんだから
そこから出ていかなくなっちゃうんですよ
無知が出てくるとさらに小さくなるんですね
欲があると何かに対して欲張ってますから
心はちょこっと外に出てます
怒りがあると その怒りの対象まで心が広げてますけど
無知があると外へ行かないんですね
だから一番心の範囲が狭い
小さい そういうわけで
悪の心は小さくて狭いんですね
それで貪瞋痴がない状態ということで
かなり無制限で心は広げることはできるんです
だから仏教の善というのは
いつでも否定形入れて言ってるのはそういうわけで
貪瞋痴と不貪不瞋不痴と
お釈迦様は単語がなくて困ったわけじゃないんです
小説家みたいに言語は素晴らしい能力なかったとか
違います それはもうブッダ言われるものは完全完璧で
もうどうにもならないものですからね
意味があって 深い意味があって
そういうふうにしているんです
ポジティブな言葉もあるでしょう
慈悲喜捨とかね 修行して悟る過程の場合は
もう全部あの三十七ですね
三十七の心の状況があるんだ
それは揃ってくださいと
その場合 全部ポジティブ単語使ってますけど
だからまだそれを他の言語にも訳できないほどの単語でしょう
お釈迦様 単語に あの 何と言いますか
困ったことじゃないんです
しかし そのポジティブ単語も明確にこの制限内
例えばサティ 気づきという単語がポジティブ単語で
その場合は悪の場合は否定形を使うんですね
ムッタサティと すごい
このブッダの用語の選び方の場合は
ものすごいブッダの智慧がね
見えてきます サティがある
気づきがあると言えば
常に認識に気づきを入れておかなくちゃいけない
だからずっと認識しているんだから
これでリミットはないんです
気づき入れないという途端
もうリミットなっちゃうんですね
それで 貪瞋痴の場合は貪瞋痴と不貪不瞋不痴としているんです
で 戒律の場合でも そういう風に殺生しないことは戒律であって
その代わり何するのかと言わない
言ってはありますけど
ただ不殺生で十分です
そちらにポジティブ的なことを入れちゃうとリミットになっちゃうんです
例えば 生命を助けることは道徳であると言っちゃうと
一人の人にどれくらい助けることできますかね
ほとんど自分のことも助けることできないんだからね
自分も妄想して地獄に落ちる計画ですからね
それで人を助けることは道徳で一度も実行できなくなるんですよ
だからその場合は不殺生でお話終わり
不殺生で言った途端 無限大なんですよ
生命はどれぐらいいるんですかね
無数でしょうに その生命を殺生しないということだから
だから道徳の世界はいつでもそうやって無限ということになっちゃうんです
戒律の場合でも そういう風と言ってもね
負でできているんです
不痴盗と それで自分に与えられたものを一回取らないということで与えられたもので小さくて与えられてないものは無限でしょうに
不痴とと言っただけでも無限の功徳というか
道徳を持っています スケールが無限になっちゃうんです
で 不妄語はどうでしょうかと
事実を語るといえばリミットがあるでしょうに
事実を誤魔化しちゃってからいくらでも喋れるでしょうに
だから無限大のことをやめているんです
嘘ならいくらでも語れますから
それをやめているんです
そういうことで まあかなり厳密に精密に語られているんです
そういうわけで 我々の心に一番後の番目の公式ですね
善悪判断する貪瞋痴 貪瞋痴っていうこと入ったら心は狭くなってリミットができちゃって
その場合も 欲の場合はちょこっと大きいんですけどね
まあ欲しいものっていうのはいろんなことありますからね
で 愚か者は無限にいろんなもの欲しいと思う
それは不可能ですよ 頭では欲しがるだけ
実際たくさん出てくるとものすごく迷惑になるんですよ
だから欲がキリがないと言っても
実際欲が自分はもう何て言いますか
得て叶っていく場合は
この希望がね いくら何でも叶うとすごい迷惑になるんです
だからそちらにはリミットがあります
まあ怒りの場合はそれほど広げることはできないんですよ
なぜなら怒りってのは猛毒だから
この十人と怒っている場合では
もう結構きついんですよ
生きることは これ百人と怒っちゃうと
もう生きていられなくなっちゃいます
もう猛毒で自分自身が破壊して死んでしまいます
まあそこでリミットが出来上がります
無知が出てくると さらに外に行かないんだから
心はね ものすごい小さくはなります
そこで自分の心に貪瞋痴があるかないか見るだけで
貪瞋痴があったら何やってもそれは悪だよと
だから人に万円あげるということ
そこで判断するなよと
試みなさいと 貪瞋痴であげたあげた万円はもう悪行為で
不貪不瞋不痴であげたものだけ善行為
例えばもう万円あげますから
あの人を殴ってきてひとたまり殴ってくださいと言ったら
それ悪行為でしょうに
[音楽]これから会議に行きますけど
あなたあの私言うことに賛成してくださいと
あのそれからおごってあげますよと
ごちそうしてきますよと
人にご馳走さんだからってそこで得するわけじゃないんです
自分が会議で喋ることに賛成してほしくてやっていることだから
だから何かしたんだからといって善にはなりません
貪瞋痴があったら悪であって
不貪不瞋不痴だったら善であるという
そこが一番あの締まってる公式なんですね
自分の心の状況だから
まあ分かりやすくて実行しやすいんです
だから世の中にある問題は
そういうことはまあみんな行為をしてから
あ まずい結果になったぞ
じゃあ逃げようとするだけで
それはもう逃げられません
文句言ったら だってわからないでしょうに
やる前にはどうなるのかと
やってみなきゃわからないでしょうっていうのよく言うでしょうね
それだったらもう人生は成り立ちません
やってみなきゃわからないっていうこと
そういうやってみなきゃわからない単語は全く仏教的でないんです
で これ俗世間の考え方で
仏教的にはやってることは良いことか悪いことかと
まあ調べて まあやってみるんです
それだけ やると決めたら成功させるという世界は仏教なんです
半端でやらないんだと
半端はものすごく僕は厳しいんです
途中で諦めるとか すごい厳しいんで
それは認めません やると決めたらちゃんと成果が出るまでやりなさいよと
だからといって悪行為に決めちゃうと
もう世界は破壊するんだから
まずやることは善か悪かと決めたら
善だと分かったらとことんやる
一旦やり出したら結果出るまでやらなくちゃあかんと
いう世界は仏教的なんです
まあそんなところですね
今日は ストーリーとか
まあ合わないストーリーありますけど
この私のダンマパダの説法よりはこのストーリーが透けてるところが一番面白いと思っている方々もいらっしゃいますけど
その方々は自分でストーリーを読んでみてください
伝統的に繋げているストーリーですからね
なんか花屋さんのお話ですね
[紙をめくる音]